news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
now let's dig into vote by mail this is
crazy
donald trump has been continuing to
attack vote by mail
while drawing a false distinction of
vote by mail
from absentee ballots while now telling
floridians that they should all vote by
mail so the back story has been that
as the coronavirus has raged voting
absentee has become increasingly
important in terms of
safely voting in november we have never
had a federal election
federal presidential election delayed we
don't plan to do it this time but we
want to do it safely
donald trump has come out very strongly
against vote by mail and we know why we
looked at a poll on monday
which showed that among voters planning
to vote in person two-thirds support
trump
among voters planning to vote by mail
more than 70 support joe biden so the
date is clear it's crystal clear why
trump would oppose vote by mail
then trump has sort of either
deliberately or genuinely you know we
don't know
he's been confused about vote by mail
versus absentee ballots
even though what we are talking about
this year
is expanding absentee ballot access to
whoever wants one not requiring
certain conditions to be met fear of
catching coronavirus
should be a valid reason to vote
absentee often in real time
we started to see over the last 72 to 96
hours
contradictions between what donald trump
is saying and what his press series
press secretary kelly mcinanny has been
saying and yesterday
in the midst of a press briefing during
which kaylee was saying one set of
things about
the fraudulent nature of vote by mail
donald trump tweets out of nowhere
quote whether you call it vote by mail
or absentee voting which sort of implies
that he's recognizing it's the same
thing
whether you call it vote by mail or
absentee voting in florida the election
system is safe and secure tried and true
what florida's voting system has been
cleaned up
we defeated democrats attempts at change
so in florida
i encourage all to request a ballot and
vote by mail
maga or maga i prefer to say
so now trump is saying in florida
specifically
both vote by mail or absentee which he's
conceding are the same things
are safe in other states where vote by
mail
and absentee ballots are also the same
thing except you won't accept it
only absentee is safe vote by mail is
not safe
other states like nevada who have
decided to expand
absentee ballot access to everybody are
really really bad
but in florida everybody should vote by
mail this is incoherent
there's just no way around it and trump
was asked about this during yesterday's
press briefing
and he came up with some wacked response
about ron desantis is one of the best
governors
now almost everything trump says that
you just reverse it to find out the
truth
ron desantis is one of the worst
governors and in fact has overseen one
of
the worst coronavirus responses in the
country but trump's explanation was
uh ron desantis is so great that you can
vote by mail safely in florida
so there's speculation about what the
real reasons might be that donald trump
is saying hey
vote by mail in florida it's good there
but not elsewhere so a few there's kind
of two options and then a third which is
pretty ominous the first
option is very simple trump is concerned
with personal hypocrisy
i know how could that possibly be but
just you know this is the idea
trump knows he voted absentee in florida
he recently changed his residence to
florida and he's being
called out about it so he wants to make
it a state by state
issue and he's saying listen florida's
safe i voted by mail in florida
in nevada it's unsafe he attacked nevada
earlier this week that's the first
possibility
second possibility is there's something
specific about florida that he's seeing
in polls
like i don't believe this idea that it's
fine in florida because it's safe but
not in nevada
what's possible is that there's some
polling data something about florida
demographically maybe you know florida
has the fifth oldest population in the
country
maybe the 2016 results combined with the
demographic realities of florida make
him think
i've got old folks whose votes i need in
florida
let me encourage vote by mail in florida
but not in other places that's the
second possibility and always the
it's because of trump what's best for
trump the third possibility
which is ominous is does trump have a
reason to think that ron desantis
this whacked republican governor one of
the worst
in the country does ron desantis have
something planned
in florida where trump knows
that vote by mail will either not hurt
him or will help him
because a funny business that
ron desantis has planned or maybe the
trump campaign has even worked out with
ron desantis
it's conspiratorial there's no doubt um
it would be treasonous it would be
immoral but remember in the year 2000
you know the bush gore
contest and how florida ended up putting
george w
bush in office effectively is what took
place could florida do it again
so what's the solution come on you guys
know
don't let it come down to florida um
make
the results so skewed against donald
trump
that florida is actually irrelevant that
biden would win with florida
or biden would win without florida
that's the way to do it and by the way i
checked out some of the pro-trump
corners of the internet yesterday after
trump being against vote by mail
for months all of these trump enclaves
are now instantly falling and lying and
saying yes safe
vote by mail in florida vote by mail in
florida re-elect trump
it's fascinating to watch them change
their stance
in an instant pretty good sign of a cult
when you see that now here's one idea
that i will leave you with instead of
using these terms
vote by mail or absentee voting vote by
mail and
absentee same thing different thing
should we just call it
vote absentee by mail like does that is
that a a linguistic solution to a
political problem that might be able to
head off some of the nonsense about
one versus the other are they the same
are they not i'm voting absentee by mail
everybody should vote absentee by mail
maybe there's something there maybe i'm
very very wrong let me know what you
think